she is a daughter-in-law of lord
ashcroft who is obviously a tory grande
tory pierre i think lots of people
remember him from the book he wrote
about
david cameron with isabelle oak shot his
daughter-in-law jasmine
hartin has now been charged with
manslaughter
by negligence after a police
superintendent
was found shot dead on a pier in
san pedro in belize now
the police commissioner has told local
media that he
understands uh the two were friends they
were alone
on the beach they were fully clothed but
they had been
uh drinking um and he says as he puts it
that the incident seems
rather personal and not an attack this
is commissioner
chester williams speaking to local
television he says that a gun was found
at the scene which was believed to have
belonged to the officer
and a female had blood on her arms and
hands
now jasmine harton has been remanded in
custody she hasn't been
granted bail we understand that she will
not be making a statement until her
lawyers are present but we do expect
some sort of update today from police in
belize and we understand that she is
being
moved from san pedro to belize city
where she will be remanded in custody
she has as i say been charged with
manslaughter the daughter-in-law
of lord ashcroft tory pierre charged
with manslaughter after a police
superintendent has been shot dead
in belize